[Music]
brandon is in philadelphia
hey brandon how are you
good how about you better than i deserve
what's up
so i got a few questions here for you um
i'm not sure if you got a background on
it yet i watch your show a lot by the
way
thank you
how can we help so
i'm 21 years old i have about um
i'm having a dilemma with my parents
right now about whether i'm going to get
a job or um
do something in real estate and i have
uh
a few connections that um i could use
and i'm just wondering what
obviously you wouldn't go the
traditional route but i mean i
i just wanted to know
like
what it is i
could i i did two years of college i
just got out and i'm about eight
thousand dollars in debt and uh i have
the money to pay that off
but i'm uh
i've been buying and selling atvs and
that's been working out pretty good i
got about sixty thousand dollars saved
but
i just wanted to know if you would
take a risk
continue what i'm doing with the buying
and selling atvs if you would go into
real estate with the market how it is
right now if
you know
i just don't want to get into real
estate look like an idiot to my family
my parents and everything like that and
have them say i was right i mean i
well part of being 21 years old is you
start worrying about what you think of
you 10 years from now not what other
people think of you
they don't get a vote they can choose to
be cheerleaders or choose to be debbie
downers that's their choice
friends relatives we've all got some of
each
and uh but your deal is you got to
square your shoulders and be who you is
dude
um and so you know i i don't really give
a crap what your parents think other
than i want to be respectful of them
okay
but my point is if you know you've got
to decide what you need to do i can give
you some ideas but even what i think or
what john thinks doesn't matter you're
the one that matters
you've got to decide this is what i'm
going to do and guess what a hundred
percent of the things you try probably
won't work one way or another nothing
turns out exactly like you think it's
going to you have this vision of what
doing real estate and being successful
looks like or what failing looks like
and you're probably going to land
somewhere in the middle of those two
things
and uh so it's it's you know
it's it's hard so uh living a life to
avoid i told you so yeah is the the one
surefire way to do absolutely nothing
with your life
nothing yeah yeah
you'll never do anything it's like a
freaking curse yeah the problem is
i just want to know how do i convince my
parents you can't you who cares it's not
their job you don't have to convince
them yeah
you got to convince you and you're
you're pawning this up on your parents
but you don't you don't trust you
you don't believe in you
you got it sounds like you got a good
business going and you don't think it's
in your eyes it doesn't doesn't it's not
a uh a valid thing yeah it doesn't have
a certification it doesn't have a degree
and so it can't be a real job so let me
just tell you if you're 21 years old and
you made sixty thousand dollars buying
and selling atvs you're pretty dead i'm
good at it yes sounds to me like you got
your business
yeah i mean it's just not taxed it's not
on the books that you know what i mean
what is tax income is taxed in america
yeah pay taxes you have to pay your
taxes that's illegal of course it's
taxed but you need to be running a
business but you've got the ability to
do this business and make money doing it
and you need to set it up as a business
and start paying your debt gum taxes and
making sure you're setting money aside
and write a check out of sixty thousand
dollars cash on eight thousand dollars
and be debt-free by the time you get off
the phone in just a minute
uh and then you then what i would do if
i woke up in your shoes
you do what you wanna do 21 years old is
a tough
field to plow
selling real estate because you're
trying to talk people 40 years old into
spending 300 000 bucks and they're
looking at what they think is a kid
so it can be done i did it but it was
hard
and i had to overcome
the fact that i was a baby child selling
real estate at 18 years old i got my
license three weeks after i turned 18.
and i did sell some houses but it was an
uphill
extra hurdles to jump over because of my
youth
and you will have that same thing that's
a bottom line so what i would do if i
were in your shoes is i'd get my real
estate license and start selling real
estate as my side gig and make atvs my
full-time gig until you get the real
estate gig up fast enough and running
hard enough that you feel like you want
to drop the atv gig
yeah i've been doing it through college
so i didn't really take it serious and
you know my parents don't really take it
serious too so i
i do like the money how many times we
got to visit your parents in this video
don't get a vote
yeah
do you still live in their basement
no i have my room there they're nice
enough to put me up in my own room but
all right
you need to get out 90 days you got to
be going you're going to get out you got
60 000 you're 21 years old grow up go
move got it
when your mama quits washing your
underwear you're now a man my son
get out time to move on this is the
problem is you're still eating at her
table and so she still has she does have
a vote actually yeah yeah so yeah you
need to hit the road jack time it's not
because your parents are bad people it's
called growing up yeah you know you need
to move out it's time you're making
money you're not broke you don't have a
you know go get you an apartment and go
sell buy and sell atvs or get you a
little rental house it's got a big old
garage in the back you can hold some
little bit of inventory in and and keep
your little craigslist thing or whatever
you're doing to move those those atvs
get after it man
you got a legitimate freaking business
going go make you a good living doing it
and let's let's say that the atv
flipping dries up in 18 months
you're 22 and a half yeah you still got
a lot to do
then go back to college and finish your
last two years and then by then you're
selling hot like then take a job or then
get your real
we're not chiseling anything in stone
here that's right
you've proven yourself
you've proven yourself you have sixty
thousand dollars in the bank if you had
six dollars in the bank in a theory i
might give you different advice that'd
make you a professor
tenured
[Music]
you're just evil
yeah i'm just hey those are my friends
just go to break those are my friends
just go to break this is the ramsay show